Donald Trump is in Davos after months of
arguments and buildup
he's impeachment trial set to begin in
the Senate later on Tuesday Wow and the
shower is al Jazeera senior political
analyst and he's here to talk us through
it all good to see you my 1 given what
we're hearing about this trial the
Senate controlled by the Republicans
Mitch McConnell sitting down his rules
as well which is going to make it more
difficult to bring more witnesses
introduce new evidence are we looking at
a very quick process so it seems but
there's a bit of a there's a bit of a
hiccup in the sense that yes he wants
and he insists on and he's designing the
whole process to be quick but in the
same time is allowing certain votes and
each and every phase and if the four
Senate Squad Republicans meaning the
moderates among the Senate Republicans
like the senator of Maine or the senator
of Utah and so on decide to vote along
with the Democrats to bring in the
witnesses and the new evidence and so on
so forth
we can see this thing lasting slightly
longer than what is that potentially
damaging even though many a forecasting
they're given that the Republicans
control the Senate that Donald Trump
inevitably will be acquitted will the
presentation of new evidence critically
new witnesses including potentially
people who worked very close with him as
we know Boulton being one of them is
that potentially going to do damage even
if the president is acquitted well look
I mean at this point in time there's
like almost three different I don't know
schools that say in the United I'm
trying to find the right word friends
strands one basically says the president
has not done anything wrong this whole
thing hoax that's what the president
Trump's all the time shouldn't even be a
trial as what is easy to defend as I
said then there's the other says he's
guilty as charged
must be brought to justice also I think
what you're talking about is the bigger
greater school in the middle that really
will be deciding the next elections is
the
a lot of them are saying look he might
be guilty but even if he's guilty is
this impeachable going to be just
century ii if really a lot of the new
evidence is relevant
shouldn't we be listening to it all of
us senators and the American public and
I think that's what the for moderate
so-called centrist Republicans are
discussing in closed doors the last few
days is to see whether this is really
merits breaking away from the majority
of Republican senators in order to
insist that this is more important and
these people and I think a lot of the
constitutional lawyers in America are in
system or something it's a very simple
idea that it was John Adams and came up
with more than 200 years ago is this a
government of the people it is a
government for the big people by the
people
but it's the government of laws and laws
must be respected regardless of who the
person is a president a senator a
congressman whoever and I think this
idea this trend if it succeeds to say
this is a government of laws and we want
to see if the president respected the
law or not if this goes through it will
be quite damaging and all of this of
course sit against the backdrop of this
is an election year what impact is that
likely to have if we look at the
Democrats as well
Donald Trump's already branding them the
do-nothing Democrats you know these
people who try to drive me out of office
out of the Democrats counter that well I
think this what we would say enter Davos
right I think the whole idea of coming
to Davos and I think this was very
clever to come to that was to say to the
Democrats are stuck with some their
little dirty business as it were and I'm
the president and I'm not only the
president
I'm presidential and not only
presidential I will be here two years
after I wasn't that was two years ago
and two years ago in Davos I told the
world why a B and C and now I'm gonna
tell them why I succeeded in a B and C
though I the economy is still working
why we are prosperous while we are still
open for business and the idea of
lecturing boasting to the world business
and political leaders
not only is an important contrast with
what's going on in Washington in as far
as Trump is concerned it is also an
important antidote to what is going on
now on it's a question III just put two
giants buyers I've got to get your
thoughts on this as well how does the
rest of the world particularly this this
region see this impeachment trial what
how do we see Donald Trump responding to
this because the president has greater
powers greater reach internationally in
foreign affairs and he does in domestic
affairs how does the world see it and
how old Donald Trump use this
potentially in on and on an
international stage you know generally
speaking even in comedy shows the few
that they are few and far apart in the
region there's a general sense of envy
of course and of how the contrast is so
huge between what goes on in America and
what's going on in our region whereby
it's very very difficult impossible to
put any leader through such process you
know can you imagine a cc or a monarch
or an authoritarian or a dictator being
put to such process in the Middle East
people tend to kill hundreds of
thousands of people before it's even
posed the question whether they need to
step aside or not so I think there's a
lot of envy to what's going on in
America but in as far as the
effectiveness of the American president
I think it's clear to everyone that the
American president is not as as present
as he could have been if there's no
process that this president will only be
interested in anything that goes on
internationally in as much as it serves
him to win the next elections he will
not get involved in anything he will not
waste time on anything that does not
serve him winning the next election
because we all know that if well assumed
that if he doesn't win the next
elections his future in America might be
quite fragile well mom we could be
hearing from Donald Trump that were
expected to hear from him very soon when
we do we'll get you back to talk about
that thank you mommy shower there al
Jazeera senior political analyst